A sheikh argued vehemently against the permissibility of marrying People of the Book, questioning
how a man could marry a woman of the Book and hate her. He asked, "What's
the problem? Everyone loves
their spouse. How many people have disagreements and still live together?
He might like her looks, her
parenting skills, or her wealth.
Therefore, he hates marrying a woman of the Book because she lacks
faith and religion. He is commanded to hate her for her
faith while still maintaining a relationship with her. This is a
very complex matter. I tell you, every man who rapes a woman
loves her but only has relations with her for her
body. He doesn't truly love her.
If he truly loved her, he wouldn't have harmed her.
Sexual relations can exist without
love, and he is commanded, as we mentioned, to
hate her. So, you leave aside the texts that say, 'You will
not find a people who believe in God and the Last Day having affection for those who oppose
God and His Messenger, even if they were their fathers
or their sons or their brothers or their kindred.
Those are the ones in whose hearts He has inscribed faith and whom He has supported with His spirit.' You leave him and do nothing with him.
What good is loyalty when its essence is
affection?"  And love, according to all
people of the language, and God says, "And whoever among you imagines [that he is] one of them," so what does this verse
do? Do not take the Jews
and Christians as allies. What does this verse do? What are
you doing in these
texts? He tells her that he hates her religion. Without a doubt, he
must make it clear to her that he hates her for her religion and
hates her because she is an unbeliever, even if he treats
her well, until this becomes a path to
her Islam. He presents the religion to her and invites her to
God Almighty. This is what cuts off the religion.
He leaves what he doesn't like and clings to something that doesn't
really matter because God only permitted marriage to them and did not permit
loving them for their religions or despite their disbelief. There is an
impediment, as we mentioned. Not all homes are built on
love. If that were the case, then
married life would not have continued among most people on
earth. Yes, and do not marry the deceitful, nor marry the polytheistic women.
No, this is specific. Do not marry the polytheistic women. This applies to those
other than the People of the Book. It is specified for the People of the Book.
Marriage to the People of the Book is permissible, though disliked, because
the Prophet, peace be upon him, said, "Choose the one with religion." He
loves her. What does he love? He loves
her appearance for her religion. So he entered into  If a man
loves a woman based on her religion, then he enters into a relationship of allegiance with
her.
Yes, he is obligated to do what is permissible for her. If he
enters her house, he doesn't initiate the greeting of peace. He begins by greeting her children, or if he has
Muslim friends, he says, "Peace be upon you." He makes the greeting general, meaning he
intends it for the Muslims
among them. Otherwise, these are general rulings. A man enters his house with a greeting of peace. He doesn't
enter his house because the default assumption is that they are
Muslim. But if she is a Christian or Jewish woman, when he enters, he doesn't greet her. He doesn't initiate the greeting of
peace. She greets him first, and
he responds.